hello hmm sorry welcome to this video
oh my god sorry I first word spoken
today
okay so what we got here is that I cants
offense and goddamn varnish variation
which is one of the good lines against
this a5
uh-huh nope never seen that one 5 hmm
okay yeah it weakens the screen side a
lot I just wonder if if the if a four is
such a big deal on the other end if I go
Knight f3 he's going to pin me which is
maybe a bit less of an issue now that he
has weakened the Queen side okay 93 and
I cannot be terrible yeah here I was
thinking I go before but yeah before it
looks like the best in strategic terms
I'm weakening c4 but in some way I'm
also isolating his a4 pawn which could
be a weak on Bishop d6 or something I
have d5 okay so he's pinning my knight
yeah 83 is a move that I definitely want
to play at some point hmm I just wonder
he's got knight c6 coming up
one thing is if I go Bishop b---twenty
takes it I take with the bishop then my
c4 pawn is hanging that is something
that I have to keep in mind I wonder if
I should play d5 him simply preventing
knight c6 okay I have to speed up I'm
spending too much time and this is a
position where you should not probably
spend too much time because it's almost
yeah not saying it's doesn't matter but
I will probably be better with more than
one continuation okay I'm allowing him
to double he doesn't even do it to
double my pawns
I can try Queen to b3 now avoiding a
doubling on D only fr covering c4 yet at
the end there is rook c8 but I have c5
right oh it's a tactic I mean it's a bit
slightly shaky here on the C file but
not c4 Bishop Knight takes Queen takes
it it should not work at the end this is
90 for me I don't know what the point is
I can take b6 oh my goodness I can just
take b6 yeah I did not expect it not
that bit six okay yeah I was so in like
yeah first off play quickly and like
consolidate the position and I wasn't
really thinking about hanging piece I
could have just taken the bloody night
and ef4 was winning a piece again I mean
I should at some point win one of those
if he if he simply allows me to get the
wall said was truly weird but okay the
first game of a session is always
sometimes I know always tricky yeah a
five is a bit of an odd move I don't
really see the huge benefit you get an A
for okay but hmm does it help all that
much
I played Bishop f5 with blank in this
position but after G for white is also
better I think it is sharp but I think
white is better knight c6 is not good
you to d5 I think this is theoretically
quite clear nowadays and I mean black
should play Bishop f5 or e5 you fibers
also play will move after which white I
think it's a bit better but it's not
it's nothing terrible yeah in the game a
form I played before not a necessity I
could have thought so
just ignore what the whole thing okay
Bishop g4 d5 I wanted to avoid double
pawn for the moment if I go here and he
takes I probably take with the pawn
because I don't know I don't I don't
like him to do this but maybe I'm wrong
in this assumption that this is not good
hmm yeah I mean it's not terrible for me
that's clear but I don't think I ever
have anything and the engine is just
equal okay so I went d5 instead a3 we
should be to where but now I was ready
to accept the double point I mean here I
don't think it's an issue that
doubled the pawns even after short
castles mckenas quite safe
they interesting I like he six the
engine wants to push each voyage I just
had a sword in the well not something
that would come so naturally to me but
it's probably an okay choice I was my
assumption would be that after age five
I know this is not possible I can take
only 6% sorry sorry the other niche for
makes quite a lot of sense as then age 5
cannot be prevented
yeah okay well he played this and now I
felt very in a very good shape here okay
Queen d7 blindness b6 yeah but it's
already difficult I mean I get in c5 and
it's not like he can play anything he's
six is given by the engineer but that is
already lack of +2 blockages which is a
lot I mean okay if I just play here and
go look the one therefore I mean this is
just terribly weak yeah yeah Queen d7
okay I can take the knight him no it
made the position he's already pretty
awful so like +4 is a lot yeah for a
position that it's material-wise equal
but the problem is he I actually I have
F for him he has to go here and if I
just to strengthen the position I mean
I've got c6 at the end no Kim
yeah f4 wins apiece I mean I was playing
this really a little bit I don't know I
mean maybe like someone who's not yet
awake he resigned him trapping the night
in the middle of the ball is always
always nice okay thanks for watching